from banking to beer to Bermuda
Christianity to climate change and China
there are now more appgs than there are
sitting MPS with
746 active groups in the latest register
that number has almost doubled since
2015.
appg stands for all party parliamentary
group and they do what they say on the
tin they're formed by MPS from different
parties who come together to discuss an
issue a country or a sector they often
produce reports or hold events with
experts to discuss their subject they
have to be chaired by an MP and have
another five MPS stand as officers but
they can also have external members from
outside Parliament they're also informal
so unlike a select committee they have
no official status but they can use the
parliament logo on their Publications
and hold meetings in Parliament
crucially they don't receive any funding
from Parliament so rely on external
organizations to provide cash and other
benefits for them to operate
[Music]
funding can come from Charities to big
businesses to academic institutions but
four out of the top five biggest funders
of appgs since the last election are
lobbying groups this means they've
signed a register to declare that they
Lobby ministers on policy and
legislation on behalf of paying clients
appgs do valuable campaigning work to
ensure that neglected issues come to the
attention of politicians but to report
by Parliament standards committee last
year warned that they could represent
the next great parliamentary Scandal
while they said that lobbying is an
important part of a healthy democracy
and trade groups companies and
campaigners need to be heard they also
warned that there are few if any
safeguards in place in September the
government responded saying it agreed
that appgs were potentially vulnerable
to improper access and influence